I'll go and read my name Spira
welcome back to tenebrous Lake we're
stuck in a manhole that's okay though
I'm fine with it
look at this okay I'm not fine with it
what how I don't like this not one bit
I'm glad these rocks are here though
they feel very conveniently placed
that's probably where I came from
I don't really I really don't remember
son of a barrel how well you live in
your learning
isn't that right out is it now right hmm
let's go in here I get the feeling this
is the right place this is the place to
be I thought I told you bros before your
brother can [ __ ] with me your barrels
[ __ ] not all your bad before
listen up your barrels and statues
amnesia is the place to be I thought I
told you bells before you barrel can't
[ __ ] with me shake your Lantern but
watch yourself Jake your Lantern Joe
your homework man check the land watch
yourself shake your head show me who
you're working with all right what is
going on here this needs to be solved
why the hell did I do that it's no way
up is it
ah [ __ ] ha that should not be possible
come on
right son of a barrel I guess barrels
got [ __ ] on me after all I'm not a [ __ ]
come on
all right and what I did wrong what is
up for this wheel what is up with my
life
we're fine we're fine we're fine I'm
fine all right
squeeze everything is happy a little
shortcut I'm too big for these all's all
right we need to push you but how
yeah the eastern kid I should work I'm
very confused right now
oh I get it we push that down and that
will make this door open okay now I just
need to find a way to guessing this is
where I came from
yep finally a whole way I can [ __ ]
walk through all right and check this
out it's gotta be something ah just the
vagina hole god I went there
Thank You vagina hole thank you for that
I might as well waste all my [ __ ] have
so many so I know where I've gone at
least well how did I miss on this play
it's amazing it's lit things like about
like things like a mouth I'm letting
everything oh I found you
yeah that's how I roll this hour
Oh what is this what does it say the
chipper is stuck into stone but I can
splash in the water
that is love
and I can urinate bloody fantastic I was
horrible
I'm sorry about that it's okay thank you
all right
okay the chipra is stuck how do we get
it out we have absolutely nothing neat
items and this is why we started and
we're literally having progress a single
[ __ ] bed this is the hole we saw
before that make sense at least well we
should probably continue this way I
don't think I actually continue this way
that would make me happy well it made me
unhappy because [ __ ] are the noises
alright so I'm an idiot could have saved
me like five minutes it's gotta be this
way yeah I'm a dad I should have just
gone here all along but no it's fine
let's go let's go we're all friend there
all right so we're even higher now or
what is that give me that [ __ ] all right
cool
I don't even want to look father get the
chipper push the stone and the finish
this mud how about that how you about
that how about that how about that
how
so snow fog you're so loud and shout ha
ha oh my god fine we're fine don't worry
about it we're fine don't worry about it
just bet on your pants and we're good to
go
all right luckily I have two pair of
pants kind of change mine I can get by
all right cool
wha oh it's creepy as hell I gotta tell
you they do the scares pretty good in
this mud am I pretty good I mean
fantastic and by fantastic I mean okay
am i okay I mean really really good and
by I should just stop because I was
annoying all right here we go here we go
baby
come on baby you've been waiting for
this moment
oh that's right pick you up man pick you
you know what I do to Shepherd man I
combine them like I don't do that I'm
sorry
no no how do you walk now come on no
it's not fair no no
nah nah it's not funny this is not how
we got to walk around them Wow what are
you doing there how am I supposed to get
through all right he doesn't see us oh
[ __ ] he doesn't see us
is he coming or what yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes
snake mode activate
like about definite huh no which way is
it down here again Bearcat okay
everything's all raha I just wanna I
don't know something everything is good
oh shut up alright chipper I don't I
don't know how this will work
Shepard it doesn't matter it didn't work
did it what I impregnated the stone
gimme back my chepa whoa
I have no idea how that works but I'll
take it
yes sir go down there Jennifer make me
proud like you always do Jennifer I love
you Purdy I guess I love your tail
they're inside lovely dark and deep
I have adventures to keep and miles
before I go to sleep and I like to
escape before I go deep fine more than
that don't fall out in my face what
calico know anyone there watch it who's
there another chapter is that you
alright
who are you I don't tell me I'm Edward
collar you my wife yes Oh hunger no I
don't remember I think she's lying
I think she does once hurry you must
cross out of here the kids are in the
other suit oh my god your voice acting
was way too good for me to take you
seriously okay I'll do it I can't lady
but I don't think you're my wife I just
think you're a fangirl I'm sorry no I
don't think so I don't I don't even
remember the wedding I don't even
remember
I don't even how did I get to up hand up
here I was a knight in a stone place
just a minute ago
not now I'm starting things that just
doesn't make sense for me anymore
I'm started to think this is all a lie
I'm starting to think I should go to the
right but I go to the left
I shouldn't have gone to the right
that's nothing in there is it
son-of-a-bitch time-wasting and then I
started to think we should just pick up
this red dildo and ignite out a woman
uh-huh maybe they I oh yes do it all
right so I guess you can choose oh hell
no
dragon dragon I thought we've been
through that dragon oh hell no dragon
the dragon I didn't ever did anything
bad to you fine dragon fine see if I
care what what was that what the hell
was that I don't even want to know I'm
fine I'm running I'm running shut up
don't kill Joyce who did do it she to
you
[ __ ] dragons man I'll never know
save your wife your children or just
leave yourself make your choice
I'm out of here I don't even care
exactly that's good
why I wouldn't return
all right I was an impressive impressive
modest it's just that's all I can say
about it it's impressive story no I'm
not so good but the rest was really good
really really good
I can't wait for whatever next they make
them a dumb can never remember what it
was called
one of the scariest ones I played before
so they know what they're doing at least
but yeah amazing it's amazing what
people make with these as much as you
can do with this engine or whatever I
mean it's awesome I love it but yeah
microfiche enjoy this series and sky
commercially if you want to see more
that's pretty much it
stay awesome piss I know you will MA
chère mo activate thunder
every hour you're right